don't come to Shack to get your money
back
but first the dumpy guy in pajamas may
want out of the Bahamas
Fox News has confirmed FDX founder a
natural breast model Sam bankman freed
has agreed to be extradited to the U.S
he was indicted in New York federal
court last week on several counts of
conspiracy and fraud and his legal team
planned to fight it but then reverse
those plans after being denied bail in
the Bahamas meanwhile Shaquille O'Neal
or as I like to call him Shaquille
O'Neal trying to distance himself from
FTX after being a paid spokesperson for
the company and being named in a lawsuit
for it said the big fella quote a lot of
people think I'm involved but I was just
a paid spokesperson for a commercial
now I don't think he knows what a paid
spokesperson does
but I get it I once did an ad for cars
for kids I played the drums
it threw me out of the band for drugs
what do they know about fun so what
exactly was Shaq's involvement here's
the original ad
[Music]
I've done a lot of my life I've played a
little basketball sometimes I DJ I'm
just an everyday Guy what's on a size 23
shoes and checks his FTX account it
doesn't matter what I look like you know
what this thing is bugging me can you
help me with this
turn it off hey it's Shaquille O'Neal
and I'm excited to be partnering with
FTX to help make crypto accessible for
everyone I'm all in are you
so uh what made that endorsement so odd
is that last year Shaq said he was
avoiding crypto because he didn't
understand it which seems like the
opposite of all in but you know what
happens once you throw money at people
they end up like me taking pole dancing
classes
but now he's one of several stars named
in the class action lawsuit against FTX
and its endorsers for more insight on
all this we have a surprise special
guest joining me live from the Bahamas
FDX founder
Sam
[Applause]
[Laughter]
thanks uh for taking time to speak with
us how's it going in jail down there the
conditions are pretty rough it's pretty
it's brutal Greg I mean they wanted to
go to the exercise yard twice a week
they want me to shower twice a week I've
never done those things
but the worst part is there's no vegan
food so I'm worried my testosterone
levels are plummeting
I just hope you're keeping safe what do
you think about Shaq trying to distance
himself from FTX and his endorsement
the real fraud is Shaq pretending he's
not a crypto expert Greg I mean that's
like him pretending he doesn't know
about pain relief for car insurance it's
like a basketball player
basketball player that can't shoot free
throws but the worst part is I haven't
heard from Tom Brady since I gave him
that marriage advice that he should try
to sleep with eight other people at once
what do you plan to do if you uh if and
when you get out or get extradited back
to the US well you know maybe I'd like
to look forward to proving my innocence
of course maybe get a mammogram but I'm
definitely definitely not suicidal I'm
not going to hang myself in my jail cell
that's important I hope that never
happens Sam thank you so much we're
gonna check back uh and soon to see how
you're doing that with Sam bankman free
to everybody
Jimmy One Day You're Gonna Be do you're
gonna be a paid spokesperson you know
God knows what it's going to be I love
it should they be responsible for
whatever they I mean if you if they were
responsible you would not have paid
spokespersons anymore no that's the
reason why they won't be held
accountable but let's be clear because
you know we are begging on his
appearance which I feel bad doing
because I look like a before model yes
but the truth is
this is really Sound Investment advice
okay you never give your life savings to
a guy who shows up to the meeting in
shorts and a stained t-shirt yeah it's
the equivalent of a business transaction
that begins with you're not a cop are
you yeah you know it's not going to be
legit but the reason people felt
comfortable doing so is all of these
celebrities who co-signed it like Shaq
like Tom Brady Like Larry David who got
out there and were like this thing's
legit I'm all in Bill Clinton did a
symposium with this guy in the Bahamas
and he showed up to that in shorts right
like you know what's bad when Bill
Clinton thinks you need to put on pants
yes
nicely done people threw their money
away yes that was good kellyanne would
you ever endorse something that you
didn't understand no Shaq's got more
endorsements than Donald Trump and yeah
probably not as good a track record at
this point also guess what he said in
the ad he didn't just say I'm all in he
said I'm going to make crypto accessible
to all that is the biggest pitch
possible that everybody
should feel comfortable getting a piece
of the action oh look at it it's going
twenty thousand thirty thousand forget
that you can't see it forget that the
sandbankment reads the world it's always
the people with all the names
fake accent they sound so important
don't don't stress a lot of names don't
trust any hyphens no and for a man who's
not married
anyhow but Shaq you know this is
somebody who's endorsed he owns like 155
guys he owns all these but he's the guy
who's endorsed everything from Chris
Christie to Comcast to
um hotels to so this is somebody who
does he's worth a half a billion dollars
I read today he doesn't need to endorse
one thing I think they should be held
accountable because of what they said in
the ads they didn't say this may be good
for you check it out they said I'm doing
it and you should too I mean when Tom
Brady talks I listen yeah well not just
you lady huh cat uh what do you think
should they be held accountable I don't
know because one day I'll be selling
something yeah I also like I feel like I
could never personally hold Shaq
accountable for anything
he's such a likable man yeah right he
like I don't care he could endorse
killing my entire family
and I still be like I love how he did
that little shimmy thing that one time
the weird thing is it turned to me to do
it yeah nobody's gonna get mad at Shaq
because he's Shaq and if if you're that
lucky where like your face makes
everybody be like yeah you're right you
got to make all the money you can isn't
that the point that maybe they bought
crypto because it is Shaq yeah but if
you were this guy would you not do it no
I wouldn't I don't know I know you know
Mikey what's great about you is if you
ever were endorsing a product it would
be something that is deliberately
designed to hurt people so it's like you
come out and you go like yeah just aim
this thing aim this thing a dead cat
there's no liability
there's liability for you if it doesn't
kill somebody right like I I tried to
kill cat
s
win win right there look I I don't know
if you know this but I I run a global
intelligence and security and risk
mitigation firm not anymore
Square group for all your Global
intelligence risk mitigation services
and we we have people who uh do a great
deal of due diligence on investments we
have people who do a great deal of fraud
investigations now the the the
connecting thread there is that we have
almost never conducted a fraud
investigation where on the front end
there was an appropriate level of due
diligence into the principles The Entity
involved got it and and whether it's
made off or whether it's it's Sam it's
always the same there's always this is a
willingness to just set aside the
simplest part of any transaction which
is the due diligence up front and just
go with it and so you know Tom Brady and
all these others and I agree with cat
who cannot like did Jack tell you no he
wouldn't endorse it yeah what was back
and with all these other characters the
people who are responsible really should
be their agents right because they're
they're the why are you always blaming
the Asians I'm just I'm just saying I'm
not even
my ugly racist Joker
agents agents all right yeah yeah
exactly yeah we gotta move on I was just
trying to try to make you nervous
that's all that's all we're gonna talk
about up next did Spielberg defame
sharks and their name
I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now